brothers and sisters please donate as we
have come together one umah to get the
necessary Aid needed to Palestine and
Gaza donate now in whatever you can and
allow us to reach that Aid with one umah
to our brothers and sisters in Palestine
one day Palestine will be
free brothers and sisters and dear
friends we're going to be reacting to a
self- entitled woman who has the burden
of the white man in a nutshell you know
they want to save this primitive you
know us caveman you know the brown
people that's the reason why they have
this demeanor um this is an individual
um a a professor who is talking about
the issue of the Palestine of
Palestinians what's going on and the
genocide and the apti that's happening
the ethnic cleansing in the nsh show
what's going on look at her attitude
look how she talks to him where do you
think this comes from guys watch for
yourself because this is the same issue
that is happening in Israel this is the
attitude that they have look at what she
says to him is impossible whenever I
speak right whenever I speak about
Palestinian rights or Palestinian
situation you you claim it is history
I'm talking about what's happening today
I know is not history can we can
we you you said you talked about how you
don't want Israel Israel you're saying
Israel that October the 7th happened
you're placing that in historical
context I understand that please don't
say that again we don't have time for it
you've made that point five times
already I don't know what you have time
for for the love of God let me finish a
sentence man I don't maybe you're not
used to women talking I don't know but
I'd like to finish a sentence sir anyway
no you are misleading the public Now by
I've got 20 seconds left I'm not even
going to bother trying to answer if you
don't think his reaction is acceptable
what would have been an acceptable
reaction to you you've got 10 seconds
left to end occupation and allow peace
to Prevail for both people that's very
brilliant yeah sorry to you know been a
woman speaking team but there you are Dr
Mustafa Bugatti you can see clearly her
attitude where it's coming from She's an
absolute bigot probably an islamophobe
why does so many women become Muslim
these days
why she sees us as the other we are the
Primitive uneducated individuals this is
the same attitude that was used by the
white man it's called The White Man's
Burden when they would go to these
specific lands what they did to the
aboriginals in America in Australia New
Zealand many other places subh Allah
where they would go and think these are
uncivilized people and we are going to
civilize them rather themselves were
uncivilized because the stuff that they
did King leopard II what he did in Congo
killing 10 million people do you ever
hear about that never this is the issue
brother and sisters her attitude is
exactly that she feels herself as
Superior and him is an inferior to
herself that is the reason why her
attitude look at what she says oh we
know maybe in your part of the world or
wherever you know you don't let woman
speak in the Western World the Western
system has made it you woman the Western
woman suddenly are walking toilets what
that means in the following is this this
is what the Western system has done
which we are against you are walking
toilets when a man wants you and this is
probably this is why you have this
probably this attitude yeah you are used
and abused yeah okay look at this is how
many women how many men do the Western
women sleep with anywhere from 20 30 40
in their lifetime back in the days this
would be cross as prostitution it's like
a brff it's like prostitution you have
been degraded to such a level you are
nothing but a sexual object you're
walking toilet yes you have nothing to
offer but your beauty the beauty
industry is destroyed you you are too
busy trying to please the opposite
gender by showing your body parts Etc
whatever be for that matter and you're
here talking about him and oh you know
maybe this is in your part of the world
you know you you're not used to a woman
speaking Yeah it's nonsense in Islam in
general in Islam we honor woman we do
not sexually objectify them they have a
place in Islam in society they are not
just sexual objects that you put in
front of a product an apple an orange a
chocolate a car yes you are treated like
inanimate objects okay you are um
reduced to that and you are now claiming
that where he is oh you know you're not
used to a woman speaking oh sorry Etc
you are prophetic that's what you are
and so much so you do not even give a
damn about the plight of the
Palestinians he said it very clearly the
solution in 10 seconds and the aparte
and the ethnic cleansing and the
oppression yes that is the solution if I
come to your house and break in and Rob
your house of you and kill your children
yes take your family members as captives
the solution is what for me to get lost
to go to hell leave you alone that's the
solution not oh after I've done that and
you end up retaliating and we're like
okay but why did you retaliate oh let's
talk about where it started no no no no
but why did you retaliate even the UN
chter has made it clear that the
Palestinians have a right to
self-defense they have a right to Armed
resistance okay cuz they're being
occupied and that's the reason why
Africa is taking them uh taking Israel
to court on this matter so the point is
very clear you can see this attitude
across board brothers and sisters you
can see and shame on this vile
disgusting woman who's supposed to be a
journalist reporter I don't maybe you're
not used to women talking I don't know
you can see her bigotry spewing out yeah
she was probably a closet bigot it
finally came out and you saw it for
yourself brothers and sisters Subhan
Allah may Allah subhana wa taala allow
us to inshallah enable and talk about
Justice for the Palestinians carry on
the boycotts carry on the duas carry on
brother sisters sharing to show the
double standards and the hypocrisy that
they have relatively civilized they look
like any European Family Christians or
white if it was a blonde head blue-eyed
white individual and that was being
committed by Israel there would be a
global uproar but Palestinian blood is
cheap and this is exactly the point the
Arabs and the Palestinians and the
Muslims we are not human in their eyes
share this far and wide so people can
see the reality of these individuals who
are biased hypocrite double standards
bigots Islam
folks